[Music]
today we're taking the new facelifted
gull 7 out for a spin the car comes with
a brand new 1.5 liter TSI Evo engine
replacing the old 1.4 liter TSI engine
the four-cylinder turbo engine also has
an output of 110 kilowatts and comes
with active cylinder management
[Music]
silence internet fiancée our cart
estimate as current says VW introduced
the Gulf in 1974 and it has been with us
now for seven generations worldwide
sales of top thirty three million
vehicles that makes it one of Germany's
best selling cars ever and Germans
simply love the VW Golf so it's no
surprise VW is unveiling its latest golf
on the island of Majorca the island is
also much loved by Germans myoga the
Gulf's new 7-speed dual clutch
transmission is said to save up to 0.3
litres of petrol per 100 kilometers on
this top mother says this golf is as
agile and easy to handle
as his predecessor as its performance on
these narrow winding roads in northern
my Orca shows $40,000 iya shmeil antique
oven is the engine
[Music]
montesque until the gulf has replaced
xenon headlights with new full LED ones
in the top-of-the-range version but
elegant headlights are still in the
fewer frills packaged inside by LED
daytime running lights are now a
standard feature so is the novel front
fascia as well as full LED tail lights
further options include animated flowing
indicators and chrome trim panels a
digital 12 point 3 inch active info
display instrument cluster is an
optional extra it's fully customizable
drivers can choose which information
they want displayed the discover Pro
infotainment system is fitted in the
center console that comes with a nine
point two ish touchscreen with optional
gesture control and a customizable home
screen
in everyday use many people will
probably prefer using the conventional
touchscreen
either way the discover Pro infotainment
system is intuitive to handle the app
connect system lets you use a selection
of smartphone apps that makes it more
user friendly and safer too but a volume
dial would have been handy what I does
come on Modest admits the new facelifted
go7
won't set your pulse racing but it's a
reliable car all VW gulfs have been like
that customers have come to appreciate
their familiar layout making the driving
experience intuitive VW do that really
well
v-mon etwas patina on the cysts even a
truss phospho v vocalist offered my
fault it's annoying mattresses verdict
the gulf 7 is a great car with a
reasonable starting price of 18,000
euros but this basic version obviously
doesn't come with the high-end features
you'll only have the basic infotainment
system which is now standard but no
active info display and you'll only get
a one-litre three-cylinder petrol engine
not the 1.5 liter engine with an output
of 110 kilowatts which we tested it's
far more responsive than its 1.4 liter
predecessor either way the facelifted
Gulf remains a really reliable car thus
endeth Seau mid steam updates desert in
general soon reached the high-end gulf 7
that we tested however comes at a hefty
price tag of 40,000 euros in germany
you